você sabia que os produtos químicos que
matam bactérias conhecido como
bactericidas atuam como antibióticos o
uso excessivo desses produtos está
criando um problema gigante as bactérias
estão ficando mais fortes e resistentes
ao usar esses produtos constantemente
até mesmo as pessoas saudáveis podem
ajudar a criar superbactérias Além disso
o uso de sabonetes antibacterianos pode
alterar o equilíbrio dos microorganismos
da pele o que sim pode afetar não só a
saúde da sua pele mas a sua saúde em
geral não estou falando para você não
usar sabonete o ponto importante desse
Alerta é o sabonete
antibacteriano pessoas tomam banho todos
os dias com esse tipo de sabonete
achando que estão protegidas a menos que
você esteja em ambiente hospitalar
cuidando de alguém que esteja doente
evite sabonete e detergente
antibacteriano lembre-se Nem todas as
bactérias são nossas inimigas tem as
bactérias boas que moram dentro da gente
algumas delas são essenciais paraa nossa
saúde